PHIL MORIARTY: Some of you might
remember the math metal
song we did based around the
golden ratio where we took the
digits of phi, the golden
ratio, mapped them onto
various scales, mapped them
onto various rhythms, even
involved the lyrics.
And that was a huge amount of
fun, but I think Brady lost
some subscribers because, for
some strange reason, not
everybody's a heavy metal fan.
I don't know why that is.
So what I did instead was I
decided to do something which
is actually far removed
from metal.
There's a little bit of guitar
in what you're about to hear,
but not very much-- very subtle,
very gentle tones,
piano, strings, interweaving.
And what I've done is I've
sampled Vi Hart's voice.
There's a great video.
In one of her videos on tau, she
actually sings the notes,
and she's got this
crystal clear
bell-like tone in her voice.
It's really quite nice.
So I've incorporated
that in this.
What this actually is is a
mixture of phi, the golden
ratio, and tau, and scales
based around those.
And Brady will somewhere add a
link to a detailed description
if you're musically inclined
about that.
[MUSIC - PHIL MORIARTY,
"THE TAU OF PHI"]
PHIL MORIARTY: So that first
bit, those notes are based
around tau.
And this coming in in
the background--
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL MORIARTY: --that low note
signals where I'm going to
introduce in a second the notes
due to the golden ratio,
which are there in the
background, which is good.
I wish I had a piano
in front of me.
I don't.
So then, those notes, that
rhythm, are the first three
digits of the golden ratio
played on top of that riff,
which is rising from the notes
of tau, the digits of tau.
And the strings also follow
certain digits as well.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL MORIARTY: So coming in here
is a cameo by something
called "Lateralus" by a
band called Tool, who
are mentioned a lot.
And here comes Vi's vocals.
[VI HART LIGHTLY SINGING]
PHIL MORIARTY: So I've had to
do strange things with the
sampling and the effects and
frequency shifting to get it
into the right pitch,
but I really just--
I'll play you Vi's vocals again
because they are really
quite neat if I can
find the channel.
[VI HART SINGING]
PHIL MORIARTY: So six, two,
eight, et cetera, are the
digits of tau to pi.
And in the description under the
video somewhere down here,
Brady will link to a
longer description.
MALE SPEAKER: Just
do it that way.
And actually, if you're
a seasoned--
PHIL MORIARTY: So with the fine
angles counterclockwise.
So we go that way rather
than that way.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]